nous ne sommes pas prêts d'oublier
l'année 2020 éprouvante et intense nous
avons tous dû nous y adapter
riche en péripéties 2020 aura été marqué
par des crises politiques sociales et
surtout sanitaire
ce qui n'a pas empêché les français de
battre le pavé pour défendre leurs
droits avant et pendant la pandémie est
les mois de janvier et février auront
été marqués par est de grève importante
contre eux est la réforme des retraites
un mouvement entamé d'abord par les
cheminots puis porté par les avocats et
les soignants et plusieurs autres corps
de métier un projet d'eau a suspendu
depuis mai qui aura mobilisé plusieurs
centaines de milliers de personnes
après une pause due aux premiers
confinement s'est ensuite à la proche de
l'été la mort de georges floyd aux états
unis qui touche tout le pays et qui
ravive le débat sur les violences
policières dénoncé depuis des années en
france les contre expertises sur la mort
d'adama tonte au même moment et le
collectif la vérité pour adama se saisit
de cette occasion pour organiser une
manifestation près du palais de justice
ici qui rassemble plusieurs milliers
personnes en juin christophe castaner
alors ministre de l'intérieur évoque
vouloir durcir les sanctions contre les
policiers en cas d'actes racistes
les forces de l'ordre décident à leur
tour de manifester devant le bataclan
ici pour exprimer leur indignation
ils se mobilisent à nouveau en décembre
après les propos d' emmanuel macron
reconnaissant l'existence des violences
policières le 16 juin en plein ségur de
la santé les soignants à bout épuisé par
la pandémie
un manifeste pour dénoncer la
dégradation accélérée de leurs
conditions de travail une protestation
pacifique d'emblèmes et qui se termine
sous les gaz lacrymogènes
ici place des invalides à paris et des
heurts éclatent également entre casseurs
et forces de l'ordre
le 20 juin des milliers de personnes
manifestent dans toute la france pour
réclamer la régularisation des
sans-papiers en octobre et en décembre
ils défilent tu encore aux côtés de
différents collectifs de défense de
personnes en situation irrégulière
partir du mois de septembre c'est la
douche froide pour les restaurateurs
contraints de baisser à nouveau leur
rideau
ils sont les plus touchés par la crise
sanitaire et se mobilisent dans tout le
pays pour sauver leurs établissements
certains étant déjà au bord de la
faillite mais en vain en novembre la
controversée loi sécurité globale fait
son apparition son article 24 sanctionne
la diffusion malveillantes d'image de
policiers pendant des semaines et des
manifestations sont organisées dans tout
le pays et finit souvent par des
affrontements entre casseurs et forces
de l'ordre
plusieurs journalistes ont été frappés
et même en paix rhdp
le projet de loi lui est toujours en
discussion au sénat en décembre à bout
de souffle le monde de la culture
manifestent place de la bastille dans la
capitale pour exprimer sa colère face à
l'interruption de ses activités
intermittent comédien acteur libraire
dénonce un deux poids deux mesures
aujourd'hui encore était attrait cinéma
sont fermés ils rouvriront peut-être au
mois de janvier mais rien n'est sûr
cette liste non exhaustive témoigne de
la frustration de beaucoup mais aussi de
l'engagement sans faille de nombreux
français malgré les bouleversements duo
kobe 19
espérons que l'année 2000 21 soit
porteuse de bonnes nouvelles pour tous